what's going on guys this is rob patrons
my inner circle of the rob core we are
back again with another episode of our
versus series and you guys did not mess
around this week as you picked two of
the most absurdly powerful characters in
all of comics to basically square off
rune king thor and superboy prime so
without any further ado let's get into
breaking down the origins and powers of
these two ridiculously powerful
characters starting with rune king thor
also if you guys don't care i think i
might throw this up on youtube today as
well to kind of give people an
indication of some of the stuff that we
do here on patreon uh but i'm going to
assume that all of you guys know who
thor is and then just get right into the
events that led him into becoming ruined
king thor so for all the people who
hadn't seen our previous video this will
be new to you for the people who did see
our previous video bear with me here so
this all occurred during the lead up to
avengers disassemble the storyline that
took place in 2004 and spans issues
80-85 of the mighty thor written by
michael ohming and what's going on
during these issues is that odin has
basically been killed by surter and thor
has succeeded him as a terrible leader
of asgard now he kind of loses his mind
and actually ends up trying to take over
earth and then fighting the avengers and
then imprisoning them and marrying one
of his villains amor the enchantress and
thor and amora end up having a son that
grows up to highly disapprove of how
thor has ruled so thor realizes how
terrible he is at being a king and
decides to go back in time and undo all
the stupid stuff that he's done which
was basically a marvel editorial
decision to undo all the stupid
decisions they've made but after he does
this asgard faces a new threat in the
form of loki who's basically brought
sorter back from the dead and is
attempting to bring about ragnarok the
final battle of the asgardians that will
bring about the destruction of asgard
itself now certainly begins using the
forge where mjolnir was originally made
to make additional hammers out of uru
and then loki assembles a team of thor's
most powerful enemies and basically
kicks the asgardians all to hell to the
point that they're nearly defeated thor
then dons the personification of the
odin force that tells him that he needs
to gain wisdom and that to do that he
basically needs to go beyond what odin
was willing to do and do this on his own
wisdom quest so he goes to the well
where odin gouges out one of his eyes
and gouges out both of his eyes and then
he goes to the life tree where odin hung
himself until he nearly died and thor
hangs there until he actually does die
which gives him knowledge of rune magic
now the spirit of odin rescues thor from
death and then he finally finds himself
before those who sit above in shadow
which are basically a council of divine
beings vastly more powerful than the
asgardian gods and armed with the
knowledge of rune magic and the odin
force thor vows to break the cycle of
ragnarok which gives the ones who sit
above and shadow the power that they
have and at this point thor's more
powerful than he had ever been in the
history of marvel comics as to exactly
what his powers are he has all of thor's
regular powers super strength durability
nearly to the point of being
invulnerable flight command of thunder
and lightning and the ability to wield
the powerful energy attack known as the
god blast but now thor's powers are
amplified significantly to the point
that one of the things he does is defeat
the man gog a villain that had always
given thor a lot of difficulty over the
years and this is not even really a
competitive fight right like thor
absolutely crushes this guy in the sense
that he literally defeats man gog with a
single punch that actually erases him
from existence which is
insane
imagine getting punched so hard you just
cease to exist but after defeating the
man god thor dispatches loki's entire
army which had basically had no trouble
destroying asgard up to that point and
thor does this without any real
difficulty now after allowing certain to
invade asgard thor makes his way to the
tapestry of fate which basically
contains the threats that make up
reality itself intending to destroy it
so the cycle of ragnarok will be broken
but despite pleas from those who sit
above in shadow not to do so thor
basically destroys the tapestry with one
swing of his hammer and with it also
destroys the life tree idracil and those
who sit above in shadow so this version
of thor was basically able to take out a
group of gods who they themselves were
god's two gods so we know he's powerful
and also because he quite literally
destroyed reality but is he more
powerful than superboy prime well
superboy prime technically debuted in dc
comics presents number 87 in 1985 by
elliott magnan and kurt swann who by the
way i don't know how many guys know this
kurt swann drew superman for like 35
years he's like the superman artist to
give you guys perspective like kurt swan
art that is kind of like unfinished art
or like the art he drew for comic book
panels where it's like black and white
it shows the frame of the comic all that
kind of stuff that sells for tens if not
hundreds of thousands of dollars this
guy's art is on a whole different level
but superboy prime didn't actually adopt
his namesake until infinite crisis in
2006. he's basically kal-el from earth
prime which is really supposed to be
dc's version of our world where
superheroes only exist as fictional
characters and no one has superpowers
now kal-el is the last known survivor of
the planet krypton who's sent to earth
by his parents before the planet is
completely incinerated and he's found
and adopted by jerry and naomi kent who
give them the name clark now when clark
is 15 his powers manifest and he becomes
a carbon copy of the superman of the
main dc universe with one notable
exception because magic does not exist
in his universe superboy prime does not
have the weakness to magic that superman
does but other than that all of his
powers are basically the same super
strength speed invulnerability flight
frostbeth heat vision x-ray vision the
whole deal however just like with rune
king thor super boy prime's power levels
are insanely amped although we never get
a definitive explanation as to why this
is one possible explanation is that the
time he spent in the paradise dimension
basically drove him insane when his
universe was destroyed by the
anti-monitor during crisis on infinite
earth subaway prime basically escaped to
a pocket reality after the defeat of the
anti-monitor because he basically wasn't
supposed to exist and while he's there
he gets increasingly pissed off that
he's been robbed of his youth and begins
resenting the superboy prime of the main
dc universe conor kent because he sees
conor living out the life he was meant
to live and because conor can is far
less interesting than superboy prime
this madness eventually drives him crazy
now this descend into madness is the
most likely explanation for superboy
prime's increased power level since he
doesn't hold anything back unlike the
main universe superman that only uses as
much force as he deems absolutely
necessary now superboy prime has pulled
off some ridiculous feats the most
impressive of which was punching his way
out of the paradise dimension by
breaking down the barrier of reality and
then separating it from the dc universe
proper when he got tired of being there
these punches shatter the barrier and
also send ripple effects throughout the
entire universe's timeline quite
literally altering reality like bringing
back jason todd bringing all the
different versions of superman's origin
in line with one another and completely
rebooting the doom patrol which is
something that no one asked for so just
like rune king thor superboy prime has
shown an ability to alter reality but
that's not the only impressive feat
superboy prime has pulled off he was
able to alter the orbits of planets and
change where the center of the universe
was furthermore he punched through the
barrier to the phantom zone which is a
prison dimension that can contain the
most dangerous and powerful threats to
the multiverse on another occasion he
gets trapped in the speed force and
while he's there he's exposed to the
light of red suns which dampen his
powers and so he's able to escape with
the help of a suit that he constructs
that siphons and stores power from
yellow suns and then escape the speed
force which was thought to be impossible
in terms of speed superboy prime is said
to be faster than wally west widely
considered to be the fastest flash alive
and finally he was able to defeat the
justice society teen titans and doom
patrol simultaneously which was amazing
dude this guy literally just shot just
shat all over those guys it wasn't even
fair he was like ripping arms and legs
off man it was god let me tell you
something it was it was absolutely
amazing so obviously we have two
insanely powerful characters here and
that always makes figuring out a winner
incredibly difficult and this particular
battle is made even more difficult by
the fact that rune king thor was not
around very long and only appeared in a
handful of issues meaning that the feats
that we have to draw from are incredibly
limited but limited as they might be one
of these feats shows us just how broken
rune king thor is the fact that he was
able to defeat those who sit above in
shadow when this happened we knew very
little about this group but it was later
suggested by loki that they could have
been the beyonders now the beyonders are
an extremely powerful race of aliens
that threaten the very existence of the
multiverse so the fact that they were
unable to stop rune king thor from
destroying the tapestry of fate and
themselves with it gives us an idea of
just how powerful rune king thor was one
factor we need to take into account
however is that superboy prime does not
have a weakness to magic like superman
does which is significant because much
of rune king thor's power is derived
from magic however although he is not
especially vulnerable to magic superboy
prime is not immune to its effects
either so he can still be affected by
rune king thor's attacks and although
superboy prime has a list of incredibly
impressive feats at the end of the day
he's still going up against earth's
heroes not a group of beings that are
well above the power level of the gods
and perhaps on par with the beyonders
and while it's true that thor did not
battle those who sit above in shadow in
the traditional sense it's still true
that they were powerless to stop him and
so even though rune king thor's power
level is largely implied since there
aren't a lot of feats to draw on he's
gonna be the one to take the victory
here as he just seems to be on a
completely different level than super
boy prime but let me know what you guys
think down in the comments section i'm
really curious to hear your thoughts
thank you all for watching keep your
eyes out for the poll for next week's
video and i will catch you all later
peace
you